es ist zehn uhr morgens und der flieger
in riad steht bereit
die saudische regierung hat zur
pressereise geladen wir sollen uns ein
bild von den zerstörten ölanlagen machen
schon mehrmals habe ich dieses
verschlossene land bereist dieses mal
ging die visavergabe ungewöhnlich
schnell
die regierung will uns offensichtlich
hier haben
von den angriffen die vor elf tagen die
ölfelder und raffinerien getroffen haben
gibt es bisher nur leicht verschwommene
bilder und satellitenaufnahmen gezielte
anschläge auf das herz der saudischen
wirtschaft
ich bin gespannt was wir sehen werden an
bord gibt es kuchen saft und aufpasser
wir werden uns den ganzen tag über nicht
frei bewegen können
die soldaten der saudischen armee
überwachen unsere dreharbeiten anflug
auf kur es in dieser wüste liegt der
schatz des königreichs die größten
ölfelder des landes
normalerweise werden hier täglich zehn
millionen barrel rohöl gefördert ankunft
auf dem firmengelände
wenn sie auf dem gelände diese
alarmsirene höheren folgen sie bitte
ruhig und verantwortungsvoll unseren
sicherheitsleuten in den orangefarbenen
aramco westen und warten sie dann auf
weitere instruktionen
es geht weiter mit dem bus die
ölförderanlagen von saudi aramco sind
weltweit die größten
eigentlich dürfen wir aus dem bus nicht
filmen heimlich läuft unsere kamera
weiter der erste stopp ein zerstörter öl
turm wir haben fünf minuten zum drehen
der stahl ist geschmolzen es riecht
verbrannt große kräne sollen den turm
stabilisieren die drohnen angriffe kamen
gegen 3 uhr nachts erzählt man uns die
werkfeuerwehr sei sofort ausgerückt und
habe in sieben stunden die flammen
gelöscht
tote und verletzte gab es nicht vor der
kamera darf uns niemand ein interview
geben wir können nur bilder von den
trümmern machen
also hier soll der zweite andere
stattgefunden haben hier sind riesige
schrapnelle herum geflogen sagt man uns
die blätter hier in diesen stahlrohren
wirklich große schäden
die saudis sind nervös treiben uns zur
eile an
wir werden weiter geschwächt es geht
richtung osten nächster halt ab cache
hier wird das saudische öl veredelt die
größte raffinerie der welt verarbeitet
zwei drittel des saudischen export die
angriffe waren präzise und unbemerkt die
drohnen konnten buchstäblich unter dem
radar der raketenabwehr fliegen wohl
auch deshalb will uns hier niemand etwas
sagen
heimlich dass das in einem
hochgerüsteten land passiert finde es
schon bemerkenswert wie deutlich saudi
arabien diese schäden zeigt weil es war
natürlich auch verletzlichkeit zeigt
aber ich glaube das tut man um zu zeigen
das problem das sicherheitsproblem das
am golf gibt geht nicht nur saudi
arabien sondern auch den rest der welt
an die schäden immens die produktion um
50% lahmgelegt
der leutnant von der saudischen armee
raunt mir zu ich solle mir mal die
himmelsrichtung der einschusslöcher
ansehen
die angriffe seien klar aus dem norden
gekommen also aus dem iran vor der
kamera darf er nicht reden
zum schluss versichert man noch die
schäden bis ende des monats behoben zu
haben
dann will saudi aramco wieder mit voller
kraft fördern
warum führen die saudis ihre
verwundbarkeit so offen vor auf einer
pressekonferenz präsentieren sie
angebliche beweise für die schuld irans
teile von drohnen und marschflugkörpern
will kronprinz mohammed bin salman den
partner usa zu einem waffengang bewegen
er weiß dass saudi arabien allein dem
iran militärisch unterlegen ist
doch donald trump zögert twittert von
verschärfung der sanktionen gegen den
iran
von krieg ist nicht die rede sondern
etwas nebulös von ultimativen optionen
mit dieser ultimativen option meine ich
nicht krieg über diese ultimative option
rede ich nicht
haben die angriffe das leben im
königreich verändert auf den straßen von
riad sehen wir keine erhöhte militär
oder polizei präsent die straßen sind
voll wie immer
[Musik]
wir sind beim saudischen staatsfernsehen
verabredet bedu ahmed moderiert dreimal
die woche eine presseschau für sie waren
die angriffe auf aramco ein akt des
terrors
der angriff hat uns noch mehr stärke und
willen
wir werden nicht kapitulieren egal
welches ereignis uns heimsucht egal ob
terrorangriff oder etwas das den ruf des
königreichs schädigen soll
abdul majeed leitet die
wirtschaftsredaktion auch er sieht die
absicht das königreich bloßzustellen
der angriff ist eine bedrohung für die
region saudi arabien soll daran
gehindert werden sich weiter zu
entwickeln und die die hinter dem
angriff stecken versuchen irgendetwas
negatives zu finden damit sie uns als
versager darstellen können auf den
straßen der hauptstadt vorbereitungen
für den nationalfeiertag
die stimmung ist fröhlich kriegsangst
spüren wir nicht musik tanzen publikum
viele leute was will man mehr
die regierung wird wissen wie viel mir
den angriffen umgeht wir sind sicher in
saudi arabien sieht den iran
verantwortlich und andere die uns in
einen krieg hineinziehen wollen
das steckt hinter den angriffen doch der
könig und der kronprinz behandeln das
weise und rollen das politisch lösen auf
die richtige art und weise
bislang hat sich der kronprinz nicht
geäußert lässt nur die minister reden
selbstbewusst feiern die menschen in
riad ihren nationalfeiertag alle hier
hoffen auf eine politische antwort auf
die angriffe
denn einen krieg am golf will hier
niemand
[Musik]